junge muslime in der schweiz die sich
radikalem gedankengut zu wenden und
manche sogar dschihadisten werden sind
ein thema das uns alle beschäftigt und
beunruhigt wie diskutieren muslime
darüber wie reagiert man in moscheen in
muslimischen verbänden wenn sich
fanatismus und intoleranz bemerkbar
machen
solche fragen diskutiere ich mit meinen
gästen
beides muslime auch mit man zu
psychologen aus berlin und pascal
gemperli präsident des dachverbandes
muslimischer organisationen im kanton
waadt pascal gemperli das thema
radikalisierter muslime ist ein thema
das uns alle bewegt das hoch emotionalen
hoch brisant ist wie diskutiert man bei
ihnen in den verbänden und in den
moscheen über dieses thema also leute
sind natürlich erstmal schockierten
traurig wenn meldungen kommen dass leute
in den krieg reißen und oder sonst
welche gewalt hatten vollbringen oder
oder durchführen also erst sehr viel
power und und auch ein schock also 5 1
für jemand der kinder hat ist das etwas
vom schlimmsten muss man sich vorstellen
kann und der aktion sind gespräche also
diskussion es gibt diskussionen von
museen
wir werden jetzt im kanton waadt auch
eine tagung organisieren die wir es
jedes jahr durchführen zu wechselnden
themen und dieses jahr
irgendwann im frühling dann wird das
thema sein gewalt und da werden auch
solche punkte diskutieren ich habe es
wichtig dass man solche punkte offen
transparent und auch kritisch diskutiert
damit an weiterkommen kann man so sie
sind palästinensischer herkunft sagen
von sich sie seien früher selbst
radikaler gewesen
heute arbeiten sie gegen die
radikalisierung junger muslime in
verschiedenen projekten
offenbar ist ihre arbeit gefährlich sie
stehen unter personenschutz warum
eigentlich
vielmehr wegen meines buches und weil
ich eigentlich eine kritische stimme bin
weil ich auch die muslime selbst
in der verantwortung ziehen will weil
ich auch eigentlich diese religion
reformieren will ich will inhalte
präsentieren besonders für junge
menschen die mit radikalem gedankengut
nicht mehr gemeinsamkeiten hat und das
macht paar leute wurden die nicht
gelernt haben kritisch zu denken und
kritisch zu hinterfragen wie genau muss
ich mir den ihre arbeit vorstellen sie
haben ihr buch erwähnte kommen darauf
noch zu sprechen
sie sind viel unterwegs für vorträge
aber sie arbeiten auch ganz unmittelbar
mit muslimischen jugendlichen zusammen
wie muss ich mir ihre arbeit ganz
konkret vor nicht nur mit jugendlicher
insgesamt nicht nur muslime ich bin in
schulen unterwegs und versucht die
jugendliche zum nachdenken zu bringen
ich gehe nicht mit powerpoint und mit
vorwissen und sagt dass es richtig und
das ist falsch und es geht vielmehr
darum die jugendliche nach ihren
meinungen zu fragen räume zu schaffen wo
sie wohl fühlen wo sie ihre meinung
sagen kann ohne verurteilt zu werden
ohne schief geguckt zu werden und mit
das was sie sagen versuche ich sie zum
nachdenken zu bringen
denkanstöße geben alternativen zeigen
das ist präventionsarbeit die brauchen
wir überall flächendeckend in
deutschland in europa um die jugendliche
einfach zur immunisierung gegen solche
radikalen gedankengut
aber ich arbeite auch in hat dass es
eine beratungsstelle wo eltern anrufen
können angehörige anrufen kann wenn ihre
kinder store radikal sind oder schon
ausgereift sind also ds oder al qaida
angeschlossen haben das ist keine
einfache arbeit solche jugendlicher
durch die eltern dann zu der
radikalisieren oder dazu zu bringen
zurück zu kommen oder nicht mehr radikal
zu werden also zwei stoßrichtungen die
eine ist die prävention und das andere
dann wieder der radikalisierung diesem
projekt hat das international auch
bekannt geworden ist
können sie sich vorstellen dass in ihren
verbänden moscheen interesse an der
arbeit von hermann zu haben
prinzipiell ja also ich denke alles was
man tun kann um
ich mag das wort hat tausende lichter
für mich ist er hat etwas ganz anderes
und leider haben wir die deutungshoheit
über die terminlich und verloren
die jugendlichen die sich machen muss
tiger sie gehen dahin und scheinbar
wären sie zu terroristen oder
offensichtlich können sind terrorist
nummer soll das benennen sowie hat meint
etwas ganz anderes für mich auf alle
fälle und würde sagen die große mehrzahl
der muslime und leider wird der begriff
kein no begriff ist seliger vertretung
falsch dargestellt
frage also natürlich alles was man
machen kann meine große fahrer in der
ganzen debatte ist welche ressourcen
können wir einsetzen zum beispiel ziel
und was sind überhaupt die betroffenen
also wenn ich schaue im kanton waadt es
sind zwei junge leute nach syrien
gegangen
in den letzten zehn jahren und das sind
zwei leute oft von 30.000 muslimen
kanton hat über zehn jahre und dass die
frage was was sollen wir machen
also was lohnt sich auch da aufzusetzen
strukturen an programmen und das ist
auch die frage was können wirklich
konkret machen um konkret auf mit den
ressourcen die wir haben wirklich etwas
effizientes aufzusetzen
also ich bin nicht der meinung dass wir
nur und mit dem ass oder mit den
jugendlichen die nach nach syrien und
irak ausreifen das ist nur die spitze
des eisberges komisch islamismus oder
gewalt eine eine eine begriff der wie
anders definieren müssen und war für
mich jeder jugendliche der auf vecsey
deine religion als eine ausschließende
ideologie versteht jeder muslim der der
meinung ist es besser weil er muslim ist
und frauen die kein kopftuch tragen
abwerten muss ist ein art von islamismus
eine art von gewalt jeder der in den
moscheen antisemitische einstellungen
erden wir bekommen
jeder der auf geschlechtertrennung
passierte glaube präsentiert jeder der
der sexualität tabuisierte auf eine
bestrafung gott glaubt jeder der
versucht andere zu missionieren anderen
von ihnen den leben retten zu wollen ist
ein art von islamismus und da fing die
arbeit der moscheen
es reicht nicht nur mahnwachen und erden
welche presseerklärung heraus zu bringen
sondern wir müssen in der lage sein wir
muslime eine glaube zu präsentieren die
mit solchen radikalen gedankengut nicht
mehr gemeinsamkeiten hat und diese
gedanken gut findet nicht bei
terrorismus hervor an der ich meine
arbeit anständige zu weit über
stellungnahmen und man machen hinaus
dass es gibt jugendarbeit es gibt
diskussionsrunden es gibt die tagung die
gefahren gesprochen habe also da wird
wirklich viel mehr arbeit getan als
nummer 1 machen
sind sie bereit zum beispiel eine glaube
zu präsentieren wo jugendliche anfang
die texte die heilige texte kritisch zu
interpretieren sind sie bereit an gott
zu präsentieren der barmherzige
barmherzig ist und nicht immer mit der
hülle droht das sind die einfachste aber
die wichtigste aspekte die wir jetzt
gerade brauchen um die jugendliche von
solchen radikalen tendenzen zu retten
und das technologie ist ein grund für
radikalisierung nicht die einzige es
gibt auch soziologische politischer
grund es gibt andere psychologische
gründe aber die theologie ist auch
wichtig und wir konnten nicht ausblenden
wie können nicht nur von den
verantwortung der mehrheitsgesellschaft
reden die haben auch verantwortung aber
wir muslime müssen in unsere gemeinden
anfang solche kritische fragen zu
stellen ansonsten verlieren wir
natürlich ich bin mit dem zum größten
teil einverstanden so gott ist auch
barmherzig die muslime seines jedes mal
beim beten und auch die kritische
auseinandersetzung mit den texten ist
natürlich wichtig sie kritisieren die
das buchstabengetreu auslegung des
korans und das ist riskant ist das kann
man natürlich so nicht machen aber das
macht ja auch fast keine muslime oder
sogar sagen nicht mal die es und so
weiter machen das was machen die den
ganzen korpus und picken sich das haus
was irgendwelche politischen programm
passt selbst die legen es nicht einfach
buchstabengetreu aus als die
interpretieren auch interpretieren was
passt mir jetzt und das nehme ich dann
wenig ihre meinung aber es geht darum
dass wir eine patriarchalische
gottesbild präsentieren der nicht
hinterfragen zuletzt eher nicht
kritisches denken zulässt und das hat
mit den texten zu tun das steht so im
koran und so muss ich das verstehen
und ich darf nicht fragen stellen und
das ist das was wir jetzt gerade
brauchen diese kritisches denken ist
einfach das wichtigste bei der
bekämpfung von radikalisierung da würde
ich nicht gerne nachfragen welche
angebote haben sie denn in ihren
waadtländer moscheen gibt es solche
angebote lernangebote für junge aber
vielleicht auch für ältere muslime die
genau dieses selbstkritische islamisches
denken fördern würden ja es gibt
diskussionsrunden wo natürlich kritisch
diskutiert wird
es gibt auch für die jungen dahin sie
kommen ja es gibt es gibt schulen das
ist eine am samstag und am sonntag war
das alles aus der schule passieren muss
es gibt diskussionsrunden es gibt wie
gesagt religionsunterricht aber ich
denke wichtig ist dass für das nicht aus
das fokussieren sondern auch aus den auf
andere aktivitäten also jungen sollen
auch recht sich sportlich betätigen
alles klappt jetzt es ist wichtig
vielleicht auch entsprechende
christlichen jugendgruppen dass man
jungen einfach einbinden
die müssen das zu tun haben wir müssen
eine identität haben sie müssen eine
rolle haben wir müssen eine gruppe haben
und das geht über das theologische
hinaus aber bleiben wir noch einen
moment beiden inhalten
ich erinnere mich als ich als kind die
moschee besucht habe wurde klassisch
arabisch unterricht koran unterricht
vermittelt ohne dass wirklich auf die
inhalte eingegangen worden wäre
heute haben wir aber neue lehrmittel und
frage mich wie bekannt sind wie wir
haben lehrmittel die mit neuen konzepten
die dass das denken dass die vielfalt
die islamische vielfalt thematisieren
können die frage stellen wie bin dass
ich was ist eigentlich islam welche form
von islam braucht es wie können wir mit
unterschiedlichen muslimischen
identitäten umgehen wie können männer
und frauen kooperativ in der
gesellschaft sich engagieren sind dieser
lehrmittel erkannt sind sie gewünscht
denken sie da besteht eine gewisse
offenheit die sind bestimmt gewünscht
ich würde sogar sagen das was alles
verfügbar ist das natürlich gut ist dass
man fängt sich auch das scheint mir
ziemlich gut zu sein ich muss zugeben
das kenne ich jetzt persönlich nicht
ist auch deutschsprachig wir brauchen
teilweise material aus frankreich und
das muss natürlich gutes material sein
also spricht dass das ganze die
reduziert die diversität darstellt und
und ich glaube es ist ein bedarf da auch
nach guten ressourcen also natürlich
moschee sind nicht gleich moscheen ich
kenne ihre gemeinde nicht und es kann
sein dass sie auch sein sehr guter
kritische arbeit machen solche material
brauchen wir aber nicht nur in den
moscheen oder vor allem in den schulen
wir brauchen auch in den schulen da
kunden wir die jugendliche erreichen da
sind die jugend sicher mindestens zehn
jahren und da können wir viel erreichen
indem wir kritisches denken fördern
indem wir eine islamverständnis anbieten
der mit radikalen tendenzen nichts zu
tun wurde islam mit seiner vielfalt mit
seiner sehr unterschiedliche definition
und interpretationen einfach angeboten
wird und das ist nicht der fall wenn die
jugendliche in eine gemeinde gehen diese
radikalen tendenzen hat die eigentlich
buchstaben treu ihre glaube präsentiert
er nur kommen und lernt den koran
auswendig dann bist du in den himmel und
windel sünden hafte verhalten hast dann
landest du in der hölle das sind aspekte
die wir in diese gesellschaft nicht
tolerieren dürfen das ist der basis an
dem die amerikaner ihre ideologie dann
aufbauen
deshalb glaube ich ist auch die arbeit
der verbände sei das auf kantonsebene
oder auf schweizer heben ist sehr
wichtig weil da kommt die ganze
diversität zusammen ich glaube was nicht
nützlich ist wenn eine moschee irgendwo
selbstständig ist und nicht eingebunden
ist in das größeres ganzes wald weil da
kommen die verschiedenen ansichten
zusammen und da kommen die verschiedenen
kulturen der herbst länder zusammen und
da wird kontrovers diskutiert und da
gibt es diskussionen und da glaube ich
haben die verbände eine ganz wichtige
rolle
und das ist etwas was sich in einem buch
bisschen vermisse zu hause haben oft
wenn sie quasi die akteure wer da was
machen sollte bezüglich wer kann das
diktieren wer kann radikalität
detektieren wer sind die das netzwerk
und so weiter und da haben sie
eigentlich überall die moscheen imame
verbände außen vor gelassen
und das da glaube ich gibt es mehr zu
tun weil ich der meinung bin die schule
hat einen besseren zugang und die schule
kann besser das koordinieren ich bin der
meinung dass die moscheen bis jetzt kaum
was getan haben ich bin der meinung dass
wir die entwicklungen der letzten jahren
verschlafen haben dass wir sehr wohl die
opferrolle gepflegt haben die
feindbilder geschafft haben die
theologie geschafft haben an dem die
radikal ihre zukünftige ideologie
aufbauen und da bin ich ja gebe ich auch
recht skeptisch wenn ich darum geht dass
jetzt die muslime auf einmal wie
verbände die für präventionsarbeit
übernehmen wollen ich sehe wie alles
teil der lösung aber mittlerweile auch
alles teil des problems wenn sie sich
nicht bereit werden kontrovers mit den
inhalten auseinanderzusetzen
also ich glaube das wird gemacht also
für mich ganz deutlich teil der lösung
und ich sehe es auch nicht als jetzt
übernahme der präventionsarbeit das kann
nicht sein
weil die probleme ursprünglich sind
meiner meinung nach sehr stärker
psychologischer stärker sozial
soziologisch nicht nur aber auch
biologisch das kommt hier ein buch auch
stark raus das ist ja auch darum die
jugend geht der vater den ich da war
häusliche gelassen lassen sie uns ganz
konkret auf das buch auf das buch zu
sprechen kommen auf die inhalte aber
zunächst einmal auf den titel
sie nennen es atmet man zur generation
auch nach wie kommen sie zu diesem titel
ich muss sagen ich weiter erstaunt ich
wollte die dimensionen diese problematik
darstellen
ich will nicht über die ess- und al
qaida reden
ich will nicht nur über die terroristen
reden generation aller sind jugendliche
die unter uns leben die teil dieser
gesellschaft sind teil von schweiz ist
teil von deutschland denn das sind
deutscher europäischer zustände
das sind auch leitet und da geht es mir
nicht um denjenigen die vom
verfassungsschutz und
nachrichtendiensten beobachtet werden da
sind keine radikaler aber das ist der
wohl von dem die radikalen ihre
zukünftigen kinder irgendwie fischen
konnte das sind jugendliche die
buchstaben treu ihre religion
praktizieren die an bestrafen oder gott
glauben das sind diejenigen die von an
verschwörungstheorien glauben die
antisemitische einstellungen haben die
sehr problematische geschlechterrollen
in sich tragen die eigentlich die die
sexualität tabuisieren die sich auf
werten weil wir nur muslime sind und
andere menschen abwerten
die religion wurde für diese generation
alles eine die einzige
identitätsstiftender merkmalen geworden
und da sind die jugendlichen die wir
noch erreichen konnten
die salafisten die islamisten die aus
reifen die sind sehr schwer zu erreichen
die können wir jetzt erreichen mit der
jetzt eine richtige präventionsmaßnahmen
präventionsstrategien eine plan eine
flächendeckende plan können wir die für
jugendliche erreichen deshalb war es mir
wichtig dass als generation darzustellen
nicht alles einzelnen die irgendwie nach
so den irak ausweisen
erreichen sie in ihren verbänden in den
moscheen dieser generation von der ich
ausgehe sie haben sie beschrieben als
die zweite und dritte generation also
die schon in der schweiz oder in europa
in deutschland geborene muslime
erreichen sie die mit ihren angeboten
ihren aktivitäten sind in moscheen
kommen natürlich die frage ist die leute
die wirklich die problematischen sind
die quasi auf dem absprung sind die sind
sehr schwierig zu erreichen wie sich
sagen also die höheren auch nicht davon
träume gehören aufs eis kugeln die
höheren nicht was der einmal in der
moschee in sagt und er wird auch nie zum
imam einer moschee gehen und sagen ich
weiß nächste woche aus dass wir nie
machen als dieses sehr schwierig zu
erreichen aber in den ersten phasen sind
sie in den moscheen danach ist der
moschee spielt keine rolle aber am
anfang sind wieder ja die folge
essen die aufgabe in den moscheen
müssten klarer definiert sein
bezüglich einer möglichen
radikalisierung die frage ist wie weit
wir das fassen wollen also ich hab
gesagt ein bisschen mehr mit dem begriff
generation aller auch mit dem der
definition die dahintersteht
weil es für mich ist nicht sehr greifbar
nah es ist ziemlich weit was wirklich
man weiß nicht wie weit es ist ich kann
das sehr schwer fassen
verstehst was ich sagen in halle aber
zustände die wir in diese gesellschaft
haben auch er schweißen sie was ich
damit sagen will ist
wir müssen den jugendlichen auch fehler
zugestehen also wir können nicht jetzt
weil jemand mal etwas anderes sagt ist
völlig inakzeptabel
aber wir können nicht weil jemand oder
vielleicht mal das falsche sagt überhang
halal oder so was wir können sich dann
die jugendlichen stigmatisieren haben
was ich sagen ihr seid fast schon
zukünftige coraline habe ich nicht dann
ist mir sehr auf ich habe auch ganz klar
gesagt das sind keine terroristen
therapie kann aber das sind jugendliche
die wir erreichen können und das ist
unsere aufgabe zu definieren welche
einstellungen problematisch sind und wie
können wir wir alles gesellschaft als
schule als pädagogen aber auch alles
moscheen diese jugendliche zu erreichen
es geht nicht um den begriff und es geht
nicht um den definition
es geht um jugendlicher es geht um
europäer die teil dieser gesellschaft
sind aber sich teilweise von diese
mehrheit gesellschaft entfernen und die
müssen wir erreichen bevor dass die
salafisten tun
hier ist aufgefallen beim lesen ihres
buches sie betonen die rolle der väter
sehr stark und zwar sprechen sie davon
dass die väter entweder abwesend sind
nicht nicht präsent sind oder durch
gewalt gewalt verhalten auffallen in den
familien
sie sind beide selber väter erziehen sie
ihre kinder als muslime im moment nicht
so stark weil sie sind jetzt neun monate
respektive viereinhalb jahre alt also
ich glaube das ist noch ein bisschen
früh also diskutieren bisschen manchmal
weil wir todesfälle hatten leider in der
familie
was jetzt passiert mit der person ist
jetzt im himmel so was aber jetzt nicht
sehr spezifische moment des klubs sind
zu klein
sie hat man so sie haben auch ein buch
öfters erwähnt der islam der radikalen
ist nicht der islam ihrer mutter und es
ist nicht ihr islam
was ist denn ihr islam und wie geben sie
das ihren kindern weiter ich werde meine
kinder die möglichkeit geben ihre
religion selber zu wählen
sie werden natürlich meine meine
einstellungen auch erleben aber ich
werde sie nicht zwingen das zu tun was
ich tun und daran zu glauben was ich
glaube ich werde mein kind in der
zukunft nicht beschneiden lassen weil
ich das ablehnen
das bedeutet nicht dass ich kein muslim
bin oder mein kind kein muslim soll oder
wie soll entscheiden in welche richtung
sie geht ich will meine kinder moral
beibringen ich will meine kinder die
möglichkeit beibringen zu hinterfragen
kritisch mit den texten umzugehen sich
umzuschauen andere glauben einrichtungen
auch zu erleben oder zu forschen oder
darüber zu lesen
ich will eine familie haben wo meine
kinder in der lage sind auch mich und
meine glaube in frage zu stellen
in patriarchalische strukturen ist das
leider nicht möglich und das ist teil
des problems
wir haben die rolle der väter
angesprochen dass es eine riesen problem
eine psychologische defizite die
manchmal auch zur radikalisierung führt
die radikalen die salafisten mit ihnen
gottesbild beten wir einen starken
klassischen patriarchalischen vaterfigur
dass die für jugendliche in ihren
familien vermissen und das muss nicht
nur muslime sein das kann auch in
familien ohne migrationshintergrund wo
ein mädchen oder ein junge einfach auf
der suche nach dem starken vaterfigur
und wie dann in solchen ideologien auch
findet und das ist hochproblematisch
wir haben jetzt eben viel von den von
der rolle der verbände und der moscheen
besprechen wir erleben aber auch eine
form von missionierung durch muslimische
gruppierungen auf offene straße an uns
einen kurzen einspieler an
dies ließ den koran junge männer
verteilen gratis korane wie hier in
basel letztes wochenende ihr ziel 25
millionen koran übersetzungen europaweit
verteilen 10 vor 10 konfrontiert
aktivisten mit den vorwürfen hieß
radikalisierter muslime aktivisten
kämpften in syrien an der seite des
islamischen staates distanzieren sie
sich vom 1 ich liebe ich kenne jetzt der
frage warum verteilt sie den koran
polizei als hüterinnen mobil lease da
chrom verteilt antonia sind peter looser
front hmm das wird ja das maxxi die
schweizer behörden lassen ließ gewähren
der bund gewichtet die religionsfreiheit
höher als die gefahren die von
radikalisierten aktivisten ausgeht
ja dieser ein spieler diese bilder
stammen von ungefähr zehn monaten dieser
aktion ist immer noch existenten immer
noch aktiv meine frage wann erleben wir
den übergang eines traditionellen
konservativen islam verständnisses und
wann beginnt es radikal zu werden gibt
es da eine trennlinie
das sind schleichende prozesse leider
also für komische radikal ist jeder
ideologie oder jeder mensch der bereit
wäre andere menschen abzuwerten
der auf der straße geht um andere
menschen von ihnen allen leben retten zu
wollen
wenn ich jetzt anspreche und sagt wir
müssen ein kopftuch tragen dann gehe ich
davon aus dass das was wir jetzt gerade
machen nicht in ordnung ist und das ist
hochproblematisch
das ist ganz viel gewalt dabei wir
wissen dass lief projekt hoch
problematisch ist weil viele von den
ausreißer vorher bei lyss projekt aktiv
waren ich bin nicht dagegen dass man
bücher verteilt in europa das müssen wir
alles demokratien
wir müssen in der lage sein das
aushalten zu können
ein ganz normaler koran das ist kein
spezieller übersetzung oder sowas
das problem ist dass es von eine
bestimmte gruppe verteilt wird das heißt
wenn sie jetzt interessant im islam
haben und diese koran mitnehmen dann
werden sie an dieser gruppe denken und
werden wie ihre fragen an diese gruppe
an wänden und das ist dann problematisch
weil ihre islamverständnis ich nicht
meine und es wahrscheinlich nicht ihre
ist es eine radikale islam verständnis
der fiel auf abwertung passiert viel auf
buchstaben glaube kritische fragen
werden da nicht toleriert eine sehr
problematische frauenbild werther
propagiert dass es hoch problematisch
mit unserer demokratischen strukturen
nicht mehr gemeinsamkeiten hat und dass
es problematisch ist es denn
möglicherweise gerade dieses denken in
strukturen dieses klare richtig und
falsch dieses sich gewiss sein auf der
richtigen seite zu stehen dass
vielleicht gerade der ort attraktiv
wirke diese jugendlich ist also ich
denke dass es das habe ich von gemeint
dass eigentlich die ursachen einige
andere sind also es gibt gewiss richtig
falsch dank eines gibt halal und haram
islam natürlich es gibt auch die
behauptung verboten es gibt auch die
zehn gebote und ich glaube es ist gut
und dafür ist eine religion auch da eine
gewisse ethik zu haben aber ist es so
klar dass halal und was vermisst wie man
in wien ist nicht so klar ist dann ist
es auch weniger schwarz weiß denken dann
ist es vielleicht sogar gut aber ich
denke es ist klar es ist verschiedene
gruppen klar wissen das ist nicht
dasselbe haram und halal für die
verschiedene personen
es gibt auch unterschiedliche verstehst
es gibt leute die sagen erlaubt ist für
eine frau die haare nicht zu bedecken
und für manche ist das bereits das ist
eine individuelle entscheidung
also ich glaube dass es so die die
meisten praktizieren muslime würden
sagen eigentlich nach
nach koran und nach islam würde man sich
leer das haar bedecken
aber das bleibt eine entweder oder
entscheidung also das ist nicht an mir
jemanden das vorzuschreiben ich denke
das ist ein wichtiger punkt und ich
glaube da ist die interpretation so
wichtig sie angedeutet haben und dieses
kritische lesen und dieses kritische
hinterfragen aber das wird sehr stark
gemacht
das ist für mich wichtig es ist kann und
es kann auch einen allwissenden und
allmächtigen gott geben das ist nicht
das problem es kann auch ein herangehen
das ist nicht das problem
es geht darum wie man damit umgeht und
wie man das für sich selbst
interpretieren
das ist das wichtig und das müssen wir
den leuten lernen gerade die meisten
leute machen das und noch mal was was
was sich bisschen traurig finde ist dass
es so den anschein gibt auch in der
gegenwärtigen hysterie die herrscht
weiter um unsere community dass wir sehr
breit jetzt von den jugendlichen
sprechen und ich glaube müssen aufpassen
dass wir jugendlichen nicht
stigmatisieren sonst verlieren wir
einige von denen da müssen wir sehr
stark aufpassen wenn ich sehe was
teilweise passiert auch in der schweiz
von kantonspolizeien ausgesandte
rundschreiben wo merkmale stehen was
eine radikalisierung ist da steht dann
im kopftuch das stadtbad das stets
sympathie für den islam
es ist ganz klar und die leute gewisse
junge leute sie laufen gefahr ihr
vertrauen in den rechtsstaat zu
verlieren und dass das darf nicht
passieren und ich habe da ist ein
wichtiger punkt die leute die leute
etwas suchen sie das dass das sagen sie
ja auch dass leute suchen ihnen die
täter suchen der gruppe sind irgendwo
verloren und dann holen sie die
salafisten genau da müssen wir aufpassen
und genau da darf es nicht sein dass die
verloren sie in einer gesellschaft die
müssen eine identität haben sie müssen
ihre arbeit haben es gibt sehr starke
diskriminierung war der arbeitssuche
alles das ist ein wichtiger grund der
probleme aber ich gebe ich ihnen recht
genau es hier in die jugend wir haben
eine gute junge die islamische jugend
ließ gut das sind das sind gute
schweizer der schweiz ist sie haben eher
angst dass durch diese art der
diskussion sozusagen der radikalisierung
praktisch noch ein vorschub geleistet
wird
indem man sagt die stigmatisierung für
zur abschottung die abschottung von
rassismus erfahrung
diskriminierung verliefen problemen
dieser gesellschaft und das führt auch
zur radikalisierung definitiv aber das
ist nicht die einzige grund oder die
einzige grund wieso jugendlicher
definitiv nicht das sind auch andere
gründe das konto logischer gründen
diejenigen die aus reifen das sind nicht
die versager die hier diskriminiert und
rassistisch behandelt da sind auch
jugendliche die in diese gesellschaft
alle möglichkeiten bekommt wenn sie über
opferrolle reden zu recht reden dann
erwarte ich von ihnen dass sie auch über
die feindbilder die in den familien in
den moscheen geschafft werden auch
geredet wird dass der westen der
demokratie verdammt wird verteufelt wird
dass israel und antisemitismus immer
sehr einseitig betrachtet wird das anti
amerikanismus herrscht und und und und
das ist auch teil des problems genauso
wie diese opfer mentalität und
opferrolle die wir leider auch in dieser
gesellschaft haben wir müssen beide
seiten ansprechen wir müssen in der lage
verantwortung zu übernehmen
ich habe es leid immer wieder in der
opferrolle zu gehen und zu sagen was die
mehrheit gesellschaft noch machen soll
sie kann viel machen sie soll auch viel
machen aber wir muslime müssen in der
lage sein auch eine islam zu
präsentieren der solche radikalen
tendenzen nicht gehabt wir haben vom
kopftuch gesprochenes wie geht es eine
frau und antworten wie bitte ehrlich die
jetzt morgen ihr kopftuch nicht mehr
erträgt und in den moscheen geht wie
reagieren die menschen auf diese frau
die frei entscheidet das nicht zu tun
also in der moschee trägt eine pause
kopftuch auch wenn sich außerhalb nicht
zeigt also so kann sich das auf alle
fälle reagieren jetzt passiert bestimmt
nichts also da wird bestimmt nicht
setzte tv es wird keine und darf keine
probleme kriegen das ist eine
individuelle meistens dass gewisse leute
nachfragen und sagen was steht dahinter
das kann schon sein aber sie darf keine
probleme kriegt weil da wo ich ihn recht
gebe dass es beim kopftuch ist es
sichtbar und das ist glaube ich was das
ganze sehr schwierig macht wenn sie
schauen es gibt eine ganze reihe von
praktikern von ritualen und so weiter
das kopftuch sieht man alles lang war
sieht man nicht sie können eine frau
haben ist eine super muslimen die zwei
kein kopftuch sie haben ein mann der
markt so vordergründig alles aber ist
eigentlich in deutlich weder hat er
trägt nicht die ethik nicht
und da ist und das ist schade das ist
das ist dass das
das schwierige an kopf das was ich hier
jetzt glaube ich erkennen ist eine
forderung hermann so die sie auch immer
wieder ganz konkret betonen nämlich die
notwendigkeit der islamischen debatte
und ich hoffe dass die in ganz
vielfältiger form von statten geht ganz
zum schluss ganz kurz an einfacher
gemperli denken sie dass die
debattenkultur in der schweiz die
basisdemokratisch organisiert ist
einen eine gute grundlage bietet um auch
diese innere islamische diskussion mehr
zu fördern
ja ganz bestimmt also deswegen auf der
sich die verbände zum beispiel kantonal
auch von der organisationsstruktur
anpassen also in genf sind die anders
organisiert als im kanton waadt und dass
das gerät auch eine interne dynamik und
ich glaube auch im buch von autoritären
verbänden gelesen also damit kann ich
mich überhaupt nicht einverstanden
erklären also es gibt diese debatte
kulturen ich glaube das system so gut
dass da die verschiedenen tendenzen die
verschiedenen herkunftsländer
zusammenkommen und diese debatte die
findet sehr stark statt
wir können weitergehen wir können
teilweise vielleicht noch kritischer
sein und ich glaube es geht in diese
richtung aber wir sind bestimmt auf dem
richtigen weg und lassen uns auf dem
richtigen weg unterteilt ist leider
bereits vorbei ich bedanke mich bei
ihnen beiden
herr gameplay hermann zu für dieses
gespräch jetzt sehen sie gleich eine
reportage aus der deutschen kleinstadt
büdingen
dort bereitet man sich auf die ankunft
von rund 800 menschen aus syrien eritrea
und afghanistan vor
schon vor 500 jahren kamen flüchtlinge
in diese stadt
es waren hugenotten und waldenser die
aufgrund ihres glaubens verfolgt wurden